paroles et à monsieur eric straumann
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
qui a affirmé dans cet hémicycle que le
peuple alsacien n'existait pas le
président de la république a enfoncé le
clou le 7 avril dernier à metz en
lançant à deux membres du parlement
alsacien des jeunes et je cite françois
hollande
l'alsace n'existe plus jamais dans
l'histoire de la vème république
l'alsace a été ainsi maltraité par un
gouvernement de la république
jamais un gouvernement n'est arrivé un
tel état de déliquescence
jamais un gouvernement n'a autant
maltraités notre jeunesse
vous annoncez vous annoncer que la
limite d'âge pour bénéficier du rsa sera
ramené de 25 à 18 ans quel aveu d'échec
à défaut d'emploi vous proposer à nos
jeunes
l'assistanat comme seule perspective le
père du rmi l'ancien premier ministre
michel rocard a toujours refusé d'ouvrir
des droits des 18 ans car il estimait et
j'utilise ces mots qu'il s'agit d'un
encouragement à l'oise yves thé et un
découragement à la formation
alors ma question est très simple
combien a coûté cette mesure est est ce
que vous pensez que les conseils
départementaux ont les moyens d'assumer
cette dépense nouvelle
merci monsieur straumann la parole et à
la marisol touraine ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur mesdames et messieurs les
frères monsieur le député straumann à
l'évidence nous ne partageons pas la
même conception de la solidarité la même
façon d'aborder la situation des jeunes
dans notre pays monsieur le député vous
parler d'assistanat nous parlons de
solidarité vous parlez de soutien à des
personnes qui n'ont pas besoin d'être
accompagnés nous parlons inclusion et
citoyenneté et c'est à cela que nous
sommes attachés et alors que dans la
réforme du rsa que la majorité que vous
souteniez en 2008 a volontairement et
sciemment laissé de côté les jeunes en
considérant que des jeunes qui
travaillent des jeunes qui travaillent
de moins de 25 ans ne peuvent pas avoir
droit au rsa activité
nous avons en supprimant le rsa activité
instaurer la prime d'activité et se sont
d'ores et déjà quatre cent mille jeunes
qui bénéficient de cette prime
d'activité et c'est juste c'est juste
monsieur le député parce qu'un jeune qui
travaille doit pouvoir a bénéficié des
mêmes soutiens et des mêmes allocations
qu'un moins jeunes qui travaillent et
c'est cela le choix que nous faisons les
jeunes qui sont en difficulté doivent
être soutenus et myriam el khomri en
mettant en place la garantie jeunes
permet de soutenir les jeunes qui sont
sortis du système scolaire sans
formation sans qualification et ils
seront accompagnés grâce à ce dispositif
pour le reste monsieur le député le
premier ministre a annoncé une réforme
globale des minima sociaux
c'est dans le cadre de cette réforme
globale que la question des jeunes sera
posée mais aujourd'hui les jeunes nous
leur répondons par la prive d'activité
par la garantie jeunes et c'est cela la
politique de solidarité et
d'accompagnement de ce gouvernement
merci madame la ministre la parole est